[Music]
in case it's
unclear you try to
escape you so much as scratched that
glass
30,000 ft straight down in a steel trap
you get how that
works an
boot it's an impressive
cage not built I think for me built for
something a lot stronger than you oh
I've
heard a mind is
Beast makes play he's still a man
man how desperate are you you call on
such lost creatures to defend you how
desperate am I you threaten my world
with war you steal a force you can't
hope to control you talk about peace and
you kill cuz it's fun you have made me
very desperate you might not be glad
that you
did
oo it burns you to have come so close
to have the Tesseract to have
power unlimited power and for
what a warm light For All Mankind to
share and then to be reminded what real
power
is well let me know if real power wants
a magazine or
something
[Music]